Sup man.
How you doing today sir?
Good.
You uh, you a citizen?
That's my business.
You've probably seen them before.
Go ahead and go over there, behind that other
vehicle if you'll do me a favor.
That's, no thanks.
Internal border checkpoint refusals, now a
popular YouTube genre.
I don't want to hold up traffic I want to
freely travel down the road, may I do that?
You may.
Some are funny.
What's up, are you an American citizen?
A US Citizen?
Are you American citizen?
Yes sir.
Do you have an ID on you?
Some are hostile.
And some, like the story we are about to tell
you, result in weeks of jail time
without a single charge being prosecuted.
Get out!
I was born in 1984 and back then it was like
Soviet Union
I moved to US I thought, you know, I'm going
to get all my rights, my freedoms, my liberty,
you know, American dream.
Greg Rosenberg is a naturalized US citizen
who immigrated to America 10 years ago from
Armenia.
Memories and family stories of Soviet rule
in his country of origin
infused him with strong political beliefs
and a reverence for individual rights.
Today I see a lot of similarities about the
stories that my parents were telling me about the past
if you complained about the government, back
then they were taken to Siberia
you don't have a right here too to legally
challenge the government.
So perhaps it's no surprise that Greg is a
checkpoint protester.
As a long haul trucker, he has to drive through
these all the time.
After all, there are about 170 of them scattered
across the United States.
Completely doesn't make any sense to have
these interior checkpoints
if they are saying they want to protect, you
know, the border
it should be on the border and not inside
America like violating our rights,
freedom of movement.
Keep in mind, these checkpoints aren't on
an actual border,
they just have to be within 100 miles of one.
Counting the northern border, southern border
and the coastlines
the ACLU estimates that roughly two thirds
of the nation's population
lives within this one hundred mile zone.
Greg's ordeal began in the border town of
Laredo Texas.
He and his friend pulled onto I 35 North around
midnight on September 26th
in a truck carrying a load of xerox machines
destined for Fort Worth.
But only 29 miles north of the border they'd
encounter the Laredo North Border Patrol station.
And Greg would undergo a checkpoint interrogation
like he'd never experienced before.
The immigration officer asked us if we are
US citizens.
The driver, my friend, he was cooperative,
he was going to answer it.
But I started to talk.
Greg says that border patrol took his cell
phone
and tried to delete all the footage of the
encounter that he's describing.
But he was able to use software to recover
the last two minutes before his arrest.
I said to the immigration officer
'excuse me but we have a legal right not to answer your question.'
So he went and he asked his supervisor
so the supervisor came in, he asked me to
pull over the truck to the secondary lane
and because there was no probable cause I
refused to do so.
And the supervisor said 'hey if you don't
move the truck to the secondary lane
then I'm going to arrest you.
They opened the door, they drug me out, it
was like six of them.
Right after that video when they drag me out
I was saying 'hey I'm not resisting it'
cause they were handcuffing me and they were
trying to hurt me.
I didn't get it cause couldn't have imagined
challenging government's actions
talking about constitution, you know, about
your rights that could get you arrested.
This was only the beginning of Greg's nightmare.
Border Patrol detained and continued to question
Greg and his friend
about their citizenship at the station.
They were able to verify that he was a citizen
using his ID
but Greg says they wanted something more.
Basically was saying that if I agree that
I'm wrong, that I will never do it again
that I would apologize, you know, give up
my rights, my values,
so I would never come back again to the checkpoints
but I couldn't do it.
Also he's like 'look at you, what do we think
where you from originally?'
he's like 'yeah you see, after 9/11 that's
why we are doing it.
We asked Border Patrol, Immigration and Customs
Enforcement
and the Southern District of Texas' US Attorney's
Office to give their account of events for this video
They all refused.
Most of them, they are, they were just laughing,
having fun of it
you know, they were applauding, clapping their
hands and like making fun of the situation
cause I was saying 'hey you can't just arrest
innocent people
you know just because they talk about the
constitution or they want to exercise their rights.'
And it was funny for them.
According to Greg it was after he declined
to apologize for inconveniencing the border agents
that the station chief booked him for impeding
border patrol duties.
This offence fell under a broad resisting,
assaulting or impeding arrest statute,
a felony.
When I first got arrested, I asked to I have
a lawyer I'm not going to give a statement.
I saw my lawyer after two weeks.
On October 10th, a full 19 days after Border
Patrol detained Greg along I 35
the government dropped its case and dismissed
all charges.
The problem here is that the government drops
charges because there is no case against Greg
because there is no evidence that he resisted
arrest, because he didn't do that.
Prama Lal is an immigration attorney representing Greg
in a counter suit against the government.
The fact that he spent 19 days in jail is
a violation of his rights
it's false imprisonment, that's actually a
civil rights violation.
There's a particularly important moment in
Greg's video legally speaking.
Remember this?
The agent says this Supreme Court case, United
States v Martinez Fuerte
means it's reasonable for them to be there
asking questions.
Greg says they're allowed to ask the question
but he doesn't have to answer.
The Supreme Court ruled that
'The Border Patrol's routine stopping of a
vehicle at a permanent checkpoint
located on a major highway away from the Mexican
border for brief questioning of the vehicle's occupants
is consistent with the Fourth Amendment.
But there's a catch, checkpoint searches are
constitutional only if justified by consent
or probable cause to search.
Any further detention must be based on consent
or probable cause.
They never stated any probable cause or documented
it.
And by simply dismissing the charges and walking
away after imprisoning Greg for 19 days
the government essentially punted on the central
legal question.
Obviously there's a conflict here whereby,
yes CBP can ask people about their citizenship status
but people don't have to answer and that leads
to a back and forth that you may have seen.
YouTube videos across the internet really.
Most people, most times people are let go.
-looking around my vehicle, I'm free to go?
Have a good day.
I mean I have my theories about why there
are differently,
I mean, at least when I watched the video,
Greg's a US citizen
but he's a naturalized US citizen and he has
an accent.
If you don't move, I'm going to arrest you
right now.
For what, did I, did I-
For impeding my duties!
What duties?
Is this a border?
And I believe it played out this way because
of racial profiling.
They might be arresting me for that in the
beginning
but they probably would let me go, if I just
bow down and, you know,
because I say I'm a libertarian, I'm a principled
person, I don't like government actions
but I like you guys I have no problem.
They hated me for that, so they arrested me
what I look like
but they pressed the charges because of my
beliefs.